I was a young country [ __ ] with
millions of dollars and pretty much
whatever you could have in a uh a
budding a spawning drug addict and you
know what I'm saying and and just a kid
man that that just you know I I just
loved life at that time though you know
what I'm saying when do you start to
realize that you feel like you had like
a some addiction I was well you know I
pretty much just kind of like partied
you know what I'm saying it's like then
I was in a snowmobile accident ice
fishing in Canada it was like you know
real [ __ ] up and I got prescribed like
uh I mean I had dabbled with like you
know popping a Lortab or something you
know not to mention specific drugs but
you know what I'm saying no it's fine
man I took some Somas one time
and I drove into a driveway and there
wasn't a driveway hey if someone's ain't
no joke boy Flexeril in summer dude I
was on tour with uh blink 182.
shout out what trap Travis Parker and um
I had been prescribed Percocets for
about six months and uh then they just
cut them cold turkey and I knew nothing
about addiction or you know or
uh physical dependence or withdrawals
dope scene I knew nothing about [ __ ]
then um [ __ ] about [ __ ] I knew [ __ ]
about [ __ ]
um and I had run out and I just think
I'm just done with that you know what
I'm saying and I remember I had this um
this uh process you know I'm saying I
would the bus would get into wherever we
were going like that morning and I would
go in the hotel and I would sleep till
like three o'clock I would get up slowly
you know I'm saying I take a shower and
stuff and then before I would leave the
hotel at like five o'clock I would take
like I think I would take two
pills and then like four shots of Patron
and that would get me like in the go be
me in public and you know start angling
towards Showtime you know and I remember
I didn't obviously didn't have the pills
and I laid down
trying to go to sleep like normal 30
minutes later I wake up sweating just
like oh feeling inside out I'm like oh
[ __ ] I'm sick this is crazy like like I
think I'm just sick like cold or flu or
something
and I'm like oh man and I try to lay
back down maybe take some cold medicine
lay back down can't can't sleep but I'm
like man what is wrong is unique feeling
this is like a never felt this exact
type of thing before
and then it hit me
because I ain't got no pills
I tell you am I addicted to these things
like what
and I remember I talked to somebody like
probably my manager or somebody and was
like
you think I'm addicted to him he's like
I don't know maybe so you know so were
you taking more of them than you were
supposed to and I was like
yeah I mean of course
I'd known some some addicts you know
what I'm saying
some drunks a lot of drunks you know
what I'm saying but that's all they used
to call them really yeah right and um
but for me I just never nobody ever
thinks it's gonna it could happen to
them until it does but I just remember
being like damn I'm addicted to these
[ __ ] but I was moving so fast I
said you know when I get to a stopping
point you know arresting like area I'll
take care of and get on off of them but
for now I just need to buy them on the
street you know so I was buying them on
the street and uh
story long that was like in 2004 I think
and um and then I ended up finally going
to rehab like pretty much at the peak of
miss new booty you know what I'm saying
of that I did not enjoy that you know
you're asking did I enjoy the the when I
first came into the game The Ugly
uh when ugly was my first number first
ever release as far as a single and my
first number one record and um and that
was a great time but the miss new booty
time man
it was just
trying to be in places traveling around
running out of pills just having to
White Knuckle it be tough you know what
I'm saying I can get through you know
just big [ __ ] you know what I mean and
things that I should have
you know I should have been enjoying you
know I'm saying it was a huge record you
know and just so many blessings came
from it you know but my my uh perception
at that time was was really [ __ ] you
know what I'm saying but I remember I
had like half a million dollars worth of
shows
um over like a two-month period
and I told my manager Bobby I was like
man I gotta go you know what I'm saying
I said uh I can't do it anymore man I
said I'm about to get on by the check
out of here or something I don't know
what's
and um like how was it did it get pretty
like because I've had
like I've had some times I probably went
to some strange you know I've been in
some strange places you know what it was
for me getting chunked by people like
meaning like I got the number one song
in the world at this time and these
[ __ ] got me sitting at this
bowling alley for six hours yeah and it
just I couldn't take it anymore you know
I'm saying it was just like man I can't
be a punk ass [ __ ] but so long
you know what I'm saying like that's
just the way I'm the way my account is
set up oh I want to do it that's
hilarious way when I kind of set up I
want to do what I want to do man that's
all I've always been that way because
you actually just didn't know that
somebody they on the phone laughing to
their homeboys talking about man I got
but man I got him sitting up here just
bowling alley man this [ __ ] crazy you
know that kind of [ __ ] and I'm just like
you me waiting for drugs yeah I'm just
sitting there like they're like give you
the money and then they they gonna ride
up whatever and it's I'm sitting there
for six hours on a Saturday and probably
missing some [ __ ] that I'm supposed to
be you know what I mean and just just I
you know I just couldn't
I I couldn't do it anymore you know what
I'm saying and then just tired of being
dope sick man like
you know that was that was the deal at
that time you know what I'm saying was
the opiates you know what I'm saying and
you know I
[Music]
I don't go down the same street you know
what I'm saying like like um multiple
times very often you know what I'm
saying as far as that goes but I I would
have never at that time I could have
never seen there being a day a six hour
period where I didn't use like some type
of opiate at that time and I thought I I
would never be able to get beyond that
you know and I and I did you know and I
could Suboxone is a part of my journey
you know what I'm saying I could say
that's the only way I was able to to
stop and uh and stay stopped as far as
and people say like you just traded one
addiction for another yes and no because
the difference is if I'm out here taking
uh Rock season Oxycontin and whatever
else especially this fentanyl world it's
it's this uh that's going down out here
now that's that's a whole different
level but
um but
when you take suboxone you can take four
milligrams a day this is just my
experience now you know I'm saying I'm
not the judge jury an executioner on on
anything you know I'm saying my opinion
in 250 I get your Coca-Cola you know I'm
a thinker you know what I'm saying that
could be that could be a big [ __ ] uh
hindrance to to recovery when you're
creative you create a lot of ways you
can feel yourself your tolerance doesn't
go up on the Suboxone you can take the
same amount and it's never gonna your
tolerance is never gonna like you know
force you to take more where whereas you
know when when you're taking the other
stuff like your tolerance is just gonna
slowly build I've always wanted to do
methadone I've never done it yeah I I've
taken some methadone but not as like a
solution but just as a that's all you
got
I've been in and out of the program for
maybe six years right six years I've
been in and out since 2007 so what's
that 15. and I never thought I had this
problem I thought everything was pretty
normal in my life you know and it came
on really later in you know I thought
for me but when people came in with
opiate addiction I always thought to me
it seemed like you had people that were
real alcoholics that were in there but
then some people just got so like
somebody goes in because they hurt their
back that's not a person that's
and then they get I mean people were
getting so addicted but your mind
doesn't know the difference it's the
thing you know what I'm saying like if
it's just like I know people with my old
sponsor shout out to Stephen came down
on LaGrange but he uh
he was like I ain't taking nothing he
said I don't care what happens to me I
ain't taking no pain medication he said
because my brain is not going to know
the difference you know I'm saying that
[ __ ] gets in my system it's going to do
what it does you know I'm saying
regardless of the reason being righteous
or you know it being prescribed by a
doctor or anything like that
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one